aujourd'hui on est là pour boxer deux
nouveaux produits de one plus one plus
one plus one love from these one plus à
l'anglo saxonne montlaur one piece à la
française marqué le mans bat en
commentaire de nouveaux produits dont le
principal type caché là dedans vous en
douterez ça c'est le one + noord lord
alors une phase plus question de
prononciation on pourrait dire one +
nord parce qu'il ya un des excès à la
limite à la française mais non alors
vous me prononcerai bien comme vous
voudrez c'est un nouvelle identité pour
une plus ça c'est la carte qui a été
présenté lors de la sortie du produit
c'est pour vraiment super expérience en
réalité augmentée ils ont fait très fort
très fort parce que l'idée effectivement
d'avoir cette petite carte il voir
apparaître le smartphone en réalité
augmentée c'est hyper malin c'est très
novateur c'est une façon comptera aussi
un peu tout le problème qu'on a avec le
co ville 19 de ne pas pouvoir tout se
réunir pour faire des grandes fêtes
pouvoir venir filmer et bien avec l
innovation et la réalité augmentée cas
technologies on peut faire des choses
des choses assez dingue et des choses
très novatrice donc ça c'est bien et
c'est une super bonne idée qu'a eue
wyplosz là dessus donc ça je trouve ça
vraiment extrêmement cool nouvelle
identité nouveaux produits nouvelles
gammes de produits retour aux sources
ça peut tout l'idée toute la promesse
qui est fait autour de ce one plus une
horde on va le prononcer comme south
nord comme ça on est dans le truc ou en
plein c'est une marque qui s'est créée
au début sur un seul un seul produit un
mono produit à voir qu'en 2019 qui
change avec un modèle professionnel vous
aviez un produit toujours idée du
flagship killer les meilleures
technologies pour venir concurrencer les
flagships les modèles les plus chers et
tous à des tarifs bien plus bas alors
aujourd'hui une place montaut rien et
revient un peu dans autre chose avec ce
normes en se disant on revient à ce
qu'on fait à l'essentiel et on perd pas
notre adn je pense pas qu'il parlera
d'elle avec cette gamme un peu plus
standards du wan plus futés dit pro qui
encore plus y est l'exception de ce que
sait faire une place mais c'est l'idée
de se dire on garde le cap
on n'oublie pas d'où on vient et on est
là aussi pour servir des personnes qui
vont avoir des budgets un peu plus petit
par rapport au prix du wan plus chuté
par rapport aux prêts du one + 8 pro
pour satisfaire tout le monde ici one +
va - venir chercher une cible
technophiles un public un peu plus large
je vais pas dire monsieur madame tout le
monde mais on est moins vraiment dans le
technophile dans les personnes qui
veulent ce qui se fait de mieux en terme
de performance ici on va chercher en
tout le monde alors on revend
boxer cette jolie boîte et cette jolie
boîte également je vous invite à venir
vous abonner pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement bien je vous parle de
smartphones je vous parle de nouveautés
soient des jolies zone boxing je vous
parle de monde je vous parle
d'ordinateurs je parle de passer cette
fois aussi de vous de votre vie
numérique qu'est ce qui se passe pour
vous je vous donne plein de conseils
pour réussir votre vie numérique donc
c'est pas déjà fait vous invite à dire
cliquez sur un petit bouton et là là
juste en dessous le bouton rouge vous
cliquez vous actionnez la cloche comme
ça qu'on sera notifié dès qu'une
nouvelle vidéo arrivera et ça c'est
vachement bien
alors on commence dans cette grosse
grosse boîte là commença souffre ce truc
sympa comme ça frank biller j'aime bien
l'idée
j'aime bien cette couleur sa tranche
vraiment par rapport à ce que fait one
plus un peu classiquement nôtres
calmants à la gamme beats voyez là c'est
rouge
on est vraiment dans notre show dance
espèce de bleu turquoise que je trouve
très efficace on le voit c'est une
nouvelle identité de marque
enfin on garde la même marque wyplosz
mais on est dans une nouvelle identité
nouvelle charte pour pas perdre les gens
pour être vraiment notre choix via côté
froid effectivement avec le nord l'idée
de garder le cap
la boussole il ya vraiment un très très
gros boulot marketing qui a été fait
autour d'une église à yes j'ai quoi là
dedans j'ai des coques de protection à
très sympa et d'ailleurs je vous invite
à venir protéger vos smartphones parce
qu'effectivement la ja les coke one love
qui existent mais aussi les coques de
mon partenaire et nocive et vous avez
une réduction avec le code que je vous
affiche en bas dans la description et le
lien vous avez le code si vous voulez
protéger votre smartphone à un tarif
très avantageux vous invite à les jeter
un petit coup d'oeil grâce à mon
partenaire rhinos idée ça c'est vraiment
cool mais nord pourquoi est ce que ma
petite languette facile à récupérer un
bon ok allez voir ça à l'ancienne déjà
truc que j'aime bien moi c'est ça la oil
plus l'ordre vous le voyez écrit comme
ça
ce côté noir brillant sur noir foncer je
trouve ça vraiment très élégant pas plus
le liseret là qui est bien bon on voit
bien android derrière ces 2 mars qu'on a
ok j'aime bien l'idée une fois de plus
de se dire this way nord là vous voyez
bien nous incapables empreintes
digitales
vous venez soulever pour prendre votre
smartphone comme ça alors la couleur
j'adore on se regarde ça dans quelques
instants d'avant le contenu de la boîte
qu'est ce qu'on va avoir là dessous une
fois de plus génialement ya toujours un
petit mot de pete est ce qu'on va
l'avoir aussi well'com letter et ça
c'est très drôle parce que pour une fois
on n'a pas le petit mot de pete
on a un énorme team l'équipe du nord on
voit bien toutes les personnes qui ont
bossé à distance dessus à cause du coc
vide ou bon si vous avez envie de lire
la petite led vous fait une capture
d'écran paf vous la lisez moi je les
lirais un peu plus tard on a une coque
en silicone avec cette espèce de flèches
qui indique le nord les petits
autocollants pour le branding le quick
start guide de démarrage les
informations de sécurité on a ici le das
tél 08 90 watts par kilogramme corps
1,27 faute par kilogramme est membre
2,76 watts par kilogramme toujours de la
recharge rapide et réussie c'est la vap
charge ces deux-là 30 les ont pas mis un
petit câble bleus ont gardé ce câble la
branche cancer fabriqué à fabriquer un
câble bleus que pour ça sent quand même
coûté un petit peu cher this way nord
dont neuf par là je pense pas faire des
tisons ouais c'est ça oui j'adore
j'adore la couleur j'adore alors il ya
un côté très pop un côté très tonique
dans ce genre de couleurs mais moi je
trouve ça vraiment ultra efficace
j'adore ça je suis grand fan de ce bleu
cette espèce doute même pas bleue ça
n'est pas de turquoise prise en main est
plutôt correct on retrouve le petit
bouton ici là un grand classique chez
one pluzz pour venir activer désactiver
le son ça marche
une prise usb c'est en dessous on a le
tiroir de cartes sim qui est là ok ça
c'est le bouton de volume double caméra
à l'avant c'est un smartphone je trouve
assez léger il fait 184 g
là la couleur gc le marble blue ce côté
bleu qui est vraiment hyper hyper sympa
bleu turquoise redd plus d'ailleurs dit
moi vraiment pour vous quelle est la
couleur soit un turquoise que c'est un
bleu et vous avez également agrio knicks
qui existe moi ça en tout cas j'aime
beaucoup
il est protégé par un verre corning
gorilla glass 5 à l'arrière mais
également à la vente
c'est un peu court trouve vraiment
aujourd'hui vous sélectionnez votre
moteur de recherche et vous retrouvez
google ici en troisième position vous
avez info.com dote de go google trikes
site web alors moi j'utilise et services
google donc série google ça m'intéresse
c'est un côté très pratique mais voyez
le fait qu'ils aient pas de google
qu'ils soient mis en premier c'est assez
intéressant parce que souvent c'est
celui vous avez en haut de la liste qui
va être cochée alors dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez qu est ce que vous
auriez cochet ici à ma place parce
qu'elle est moins emballant commentaire
donc des gens d'un lecteur d'empreintes
digitales pour venir sécuriser ça c'est
très malin le fond d'écran le fait
d'avoir lui d'avoir planqué les deux
petites caméras ici parce qu'ici on a
deux caméras de service assez plutôt
bien on a un écran qu'il y ait plein 6
un écran amoled de 6,44 pouces c'est du
full hd plus un écran 90 hertz on a ici
un petit haut parleur mono en termes de
performance vous avez un processeur de
qualcomm c'est le snapdragon 765 gc un
processeur de gaming j'ai pour gaming
c'est un processeur 5g vous est donc
centré smartphones qui est prêt pour la
5g même si en tout cas aussi en france à
cinq je n'ai pas encore arrivé je sais
qu'elle est présente en suisse et dans
beaucoup de pays
vous avez deux confie vous avez soit 8
gigas de ram 128 go de stockage soit 12
igad ram 256 go de stockage la rame
c'est là en effet dr catherine et la
technologie de stockage c'est le fs deux
points alors ici on n'est pas sur le fn
3.0 on n'est pas sur la lpddr2 cinq
notes pas sur ce qu'elle mieux en terme
de techno si vous voulez ce cas mieux
chez one place faut aller sur le modèle
professionnel c'est parce qu'on vient
chercher ici
non ce qu'on vient chercher ici c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui marche bien
c'est un bon rapport qualité prix
on reste dans côté du milieu de gamme on
cherche un truc un peu moins spéculer
mais ça fonctionne vous avez une grosse
batterie de 4000 115 millions perrin
vous dit de la recharge rapide d'audrey
les résultats du test d'ici quelques
jours pour l'instant c'est vraiment de
la découverte
on a le tiroir d'appli bon après ses
grands classiques on est sur oxygen os
basé sur un android dix ou si vous
n'avez pas de recharge sans fil par
contre et pour voir quoi de plus
assortie effectivement sa base de
recharge sans fil avec ces nouveaux
modèles et bien que celui là ça ne
fonctionnera pas donc on oublie pour ce
modèle là en tout cas la config au
niveau des caméras est intéressante à
l'avant vous avez un double module photo
vous avez eu d'affairé de 30 2
mégapixels
c'est le capteur sony mx 616 qui ouvre à
f 2.45 et le deuxième c'est un ultra
grand-angle de 8 mégapixels avec un
champ de vision de 105 degrés bref 2.45
également cela on se regardait un
résultat lors du test et à l'arrière
vous avez vous le voyez quatre capteurs
au sens vous avez un capteur de 48
mégapixels sultanat qu'uribe 1.75 avec
une stabilisation optique de pouvoir
venir faire un zoom x 2 dans l'image qui
va se faire sur le capteur principal
vous avez un côté ultra grand-angle avec
un capteur de 8 mégapixels to drive 2.25
et vous avez deux petites caméras une
promo de portraits un capteur de 5
mégapixels trouvera f 2.4 va travailler
de concert avec le capteur principal
pour sortir effectivement ce flou
d'arrière-plan sans le verra
effectivement lors du test et vous avez
une caméra de 2 mégapixels qui est pour
la macro pour f 2.4
sur le papier la macro l'avis négatif
c'est pas tout la mixité le plus on
verra ce que ça dit lors des phases de
test mais je suis passionné le résultat
le plus dingue c'est en tout cas un truc
un peu classique en termes de
configuration vous des pouvoirs bien
filmé jusqu en 4k 30 images par seconde
vous allez avoir une super stabilisation
en 1080p bon tout ça on le verra
effectivement aussi un peu plus tard du
mode nuit surtout un menu de cette fois
retrouver également sur la caméra de
celle fille aussi bien sûr le grand
temps que sur l' ultra grand-angle donc
c'est plutôt bien joué ça déroule bien
c'est rapide c'est pratique bon on
regardera ça effectivement d'ici
quelques jours
c'est bien le fait de pas voir dans koch
la hausse est très malin que ce soit
planqué comme ça ici donc on oublierait
presque qu'on a ces deux petites caméras
dans cette espèce de d'encoches bull
vous l'appelez comme vous voulez nos
consultants d'ici quelques jours vous
invite évidemment vous abonner si c'est
pas du seul cas comme ça vous saurez
tout sur ce nouveau one plus'' nord du
pays il ya plein de nouveautés pas notre
choses qui vont arriver
mais qu'en est-il en termes de prix
parce que ça serait un monsieur qui nous
intéresse sur la config 8 +128 on est à
moins de 400 euros
on est à 399 euros c'est bien placés
très bien positionnés et le 12 plus 256
on est à 100 euros de plus on est à 499
euros plutôt bien écouter pour le prix
je trouve intéressant on se teste d'ici
quelques jours
laissez-moi vraiment l'apprivoiser voir
ce que je peux faire faire des photos
tester des jeux testés regarder des
films pleins de choses et je vous dit ce
que j'en pense d'ici quelques jours ça
c'était le premier package inc on va
regarder très rapidement le deuxième
parce que wyplosz vient de sortir et ça
c'est cool
ce sont des petits bugs les one love bug
nord nous moi j'ai demandé le modèle
bleu il ya plusieurs couleurs vous avez
un modèle blanc de 20 modèles gris
anthracite
moi j'adore le bleu nabil même en bleu
c'est pas fait exprès alors que de voir
on va voir ici 30 heures d'autonomie au
niveau du boîtier c'est ce qui donne en
tout cas pas un one love on a jusqu'à 7
heures de musique au niveau des
écouteurs jusqu'à 4 heures en
communication plutôt pas mal cette
couleur est sympa alors en fait ce sont
pas des intra ils viennent se poser sur
vos oreilles qui se pose en fait juste
conforme c'est pas mal on les oublie son
très léger très très très léger alors
c'est pas des boeufs qui vont coûter
extrêmement cher que 79 euros alors ça
je suis pas sûr de faire un test dessus
mais je pense que j'ai plein de potes
confrères qui feront des choses donc
pourquoi pas les voir ce que dit la
presse là dessus je les écouterai en
tout cas donc il se peut que je vous en
parle la montée voilà pour cette
première découverte première prise en
main
le plus noble que j'ai ici dites moi ce
que vous en pensez comme ça est ce que
vous aimez le design vous avez ce bleu
moi je trouve très très très très cool
dites moi ce que vous en pensez marqué
le mandant commensacq wallon se trouve
extrêmement rapidement parce que vous
savez latex ne s'arrête pas et même en
été il se passe plein de choses et ça
c'est très très très cool et quant à
nous on trouve extrêmement rapidement
mais extrêmement rapidement pour
continuer à parler de one love et du
plein d'autres marques et de panneaux de
produits parce qu'il ya plein de choses
qui arrivent
et ça c'est génial pour les soins nous a
très vite car quelqu'un
[Musique]
on
plus est joué
[Musique]